[Musique]
bonjour Jean sol merci de nous
accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure vous êtes élu des Pyrénées
Orientales membres du groupe les
républicains et rapporteur de la
proposition de loi sur le Bien Vieillir
qui sera examiner cet après-midi au
Sénat on va évidemment parler dans
quelques instants mais d'abord
l'actualité c'est cette colère des
agriculteurs les blocages qui vous
l'avez vu dans le journal se multiplie
dans le pays plusieurs tracteurs
convergent vers Paris est-ce que vous
soutenez cette méthode écoutez moi je
suis au soutien de nos de nos
agriculteurs viticulteurs maréchés
arboriculteurs etleveurs dont on parle
peu aujourd'hui je pense qu'il est il
est temps de de les écouter et puis
surtout de de mettre en place un plan
d'action qui facilite le leur travail ce
sont quand même des des je dirais des
des personnes qui qui travaillent avec
une une une passion parfois jour et nuit
qui qui nourrissent quand même les
Françaises et les Français nous l'avons
vu pendant la crise sanitaire
heureusement qu'il qu'ils étaient là et
ils participent aussi à la à la
biodiversité à l'entretien de pay est-ce
que ils ont raison de monter vers Paris
de vouloir bloquer les axes de vouloir
bloquer le marché de ringis mais vous
savez quand on n pas écouté à un moment
donné on passe à l'étape supérieure qui
est celle qu'il en tout cas qu'ils ont
choisi aujourd'hui sans trop de
débordement a priori donc il ne faut pas
intervenir il faut les laisser faire ben
il faut les laisser faire il faut
surtout R réondre à leurs préoccupations
à leurs attentes mais de manière
concrète au-delà des déclarations
d'intention ici et là est-ce que vous
redoutez que cette crise ne dégénère qu'
a une convergence des luttes qui a des
violences ben écoutez comme toute crise
il faut faire preuve de de de de
vigilance effectivement ce n'est pas
quelque chose enfin que que que je
souhaite en tout cas personnellement moi
j'appelle de de mes vœux une prise de
conscience parce que cette crise elle
est sous-jacente depuis de nombreuses
années le ministre Mar fesen le disait à
l'instant et des mesures en tout cas
s'imposent des mesures concrètes et je
pense surtout qu'ils soitent écoutés
entendu et qu'ils puissent faire
prospérer en tout cas leur leurs
entreprises nourrir leurs familles
transmettre leur leur leurs propriétés
et leurs entreprises aussi le
gouvernement le le mouvement pardon est
parti de de votre région est-ce que le
gouvernement a trop tardé à réagir selon
vous en tout cas il a il a mis du temps
à réagir trop tardé je ne sais pas mais
il a mis effectivement beaucoup de temps
à réagir enfin personnellement et et
comme moi bon nombre de de de mes
collèguesin alerte sur ces sur ces
problématique hein de nombreux courriers
ont été rédigés à l'attention du du
ministre de l'Agriculture du du du
Premier ministre de la première ministre
quand madame borne donc était à ce poste
là et puis les choses les et en tout cas
les les réponses avancent doucettement
et et justement Gabriel Attal est venu
dans votre région faire ses annonces au
milieu euh des agriculteurs est-ce que
vous y avez été sensible ben bien sûr
hein après enfit j'ai envie de de de
dire hein que c'est le le rôle et la
mission euh hein d'un ministre que que
que de se déplacer sur le terrain et
d'aller au contact et sur le fond de ces
annonces est-ce que les premières
mesures celles qu'il a annoncé vendredi
sont les bonnes pour vous ben écoutez il
y a des mesures effectivement il y a
quand même on peut noter quelques
avancées on on on on peut enfin on ne
peut pas dire que que que rien n'est
n'est proposé mais à mon sens et et
surtout sens de nombreux agriculteurs
c'est-à-dire de de nombreux
professionnels elles sont elles sont
largement insuffisantes alors il y a des
nouvelles annonces qui vont être faites
aujourd'hui de nouvelles mesures qui
vont être présentées euh qu'est-ce que
vous attendezv comme nouvelle mesure
qu'est-ce qui doit être prioritaire
selon vous ben moi je pense que ce qui
doit être prioritaire c'est déjà que les
les normes qui sont imposées à nos
agriculteurs aujourd'hui euh ben
qu'elles soit qu'elles soit pour pour
tous et toute pareille hein il y a il y
a cette question de de lutte contre les
les les les surtransposition hein il y a
il y a la question aussi certains n'ont
pas encore touché la la pâac vous
imaginez pour pour 2023 il y a la
question assurancielle aussi hein je
suis en contact très fréquent avec les
éleveurs de de mon département alors il
leur a été préconisé de de s'assurer
c'est ce qu'ils ont fait et puis au
final par un outil de mesure hein de la
de la pousse des des des de de de
l'herbe en fait un outil un outil Airbus
hein qui qui définit une jauge elle se
on se rend compte que sur le terrain en
particulier sur un terrain à relief elle
ne correspond pas du tout à ce que
vivent nos agriculteurs ce qui fait que
pour parler des des éleveurs hein
beaucoup sont en train de de faire de la
décapitulation hein ils vendent leur
leur leur bêtes bien évidemment à regret
pour pouvoir acheter des balles de foin
parce que dans notre département la
problématique comme vous le savez est
majorée par une sécheresse inédite et un
manque d'eau hisique ouais on va on va
évidemment parler de la de la question
de l'eau hier la porte-parole du
gouvernement à l'issue du Conseil des
ministres a répété à mentreprise
qu'Emmanuel Macron défondait
l'agriculture à la française vous
trouvez vous nous nous n'avons pas trop
ce sentiment ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que le le Sénat défend
l'agriculture à la française et et l'a
démontré par un certain nombre de de
propositions de projet de loi
d'intervention de courriers comme je
vous le disais tout à l'heure à
l'attention de nos de nos décideurs de
nos ministres sur la question européenne
parce que vous l'avez dit évidemment
tout ne dépend pas de la France il y a
aussi un enjeu européen Macron va
s'entretenir jeudi avec coursola vlean
la présidente de la Commission
européenne est-ce que vous pensez qu'il
peut peser en tout cas je je ne peux pas
dire enfin je je je le je ne le perçois
pas en ces termes moi je pense qu'il
doit peser je ne me pose pas la question
de est-ce qu'il peut peser il doit
peser notamment sur les les accords de
libre échange et notamment sur le site
du Mercosur le Mercosur et cetera et
cetera la France est opposée à cet
accord du Mercosur est a à faire
renoncer l'Union européenne mais en tout
cas je l'appelle nous l'appelons de nous
vux votre département on va en parler on
va y aller dans quelques instants mais
il y a cette sécheresse dont on va
parler il y a aussi la question des
fruits et légumes puisququeil y a
beaucoup de fruits et légumes qui sont
produits dans dans votre département qui
est à côté de l'Espagne il y a une
concurrence est-ce que là aussi vous
attendez des réponses du gouvernement la
moitié des fruits et légumes consommés
dans notre pays sont importés oui c'est
pas nouveau c'est pas nouveau hein ces
importations en tout cas la la quantité
donc c'est C c'est amplifé mais il n'y a
pas que les fruits et légumes il y a
aussi la problématique de de de la
viande aussi he du
poulet donc effectivement il faut y
mettre un terme et notamment du poulet
ukrainien qu'on a beaucoup importé pour
soutenir les Ukrainiens dans la guerre
est-ce qu'il faut diminuer ces
importations est-ce qu'elle mett en
danger la l'agriculture française mais
moi je pense qu'elle met en danger notre
souveraineté alimentaire et
l'agriculture française bien évidemment
on va aller justement dans votre
département on va à perpignon on
retrouve pierre Matis bonjour Pierre
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
rédacteur en chef du journal
L'Indépendant pierre on en parlait un
petit peu avec Jean évidemment l'une des
problématiques dans votre département
c'est la question de la sécheresse et
donc de la ressource en eau et c'est au
cœur des revendications des agriculteurs
oui oui puce que les les agriculteurs
évidemment vous parliez des fruits et
légumes Jean sol parlait tout à l'heure
des des des des terrains des terrains en
pente il pensait éidemment aux éleveurs
des des des des des ha cantons hein que
ce soit dans le valetpire que ce soit
dans le conflan dans le capsir euh tous
c c'est des endroits qui sont
aujourd'hui extrêmement touchés par la
sécheresse on est sur le 3è hiver de
sécheresse donc consécutif euh le le ce
qui est exceptionnel puisque on sait
très bien que la ressource en eau elle
se reconstitue pendant l'hiver et donc
la la situation est est non seulement
grave aujourd'hui mais encore plus
inquiétante pour l'avenir on a publié là
ce matin hier matin donc l'interview de
du du responsable de la vallée de la
vallée du Tech Alexandre puisenau qui
est qui est le maire des clus et qui
nous disait à quel point pour lui la
situation la situation était grave et
aujourd'hui même le préfet des piréné
orientales fait organise une réunion en
préfecture autour de ce thème de l'eau
on est que le 30 janvier et c'est déjà
l'état d'urgence si j'ai envie de j'ai
envie de de dire pierre vous avez une
question pour g sal oui alors c'est
c'est vrai que une des des grandes
préoccupations souvent quand on il y a
pas une seule solution pour résoudre
pour résoudre la sécheresse euh et euh
souvent ce qu'on ce qu'on ce qu'on
retrouve c'est il faut mettre un il faut
mettre en pause l'urbanisation parce que
effectivement derrière l'urbanisation il
y a il y a tout un tas de conséquences
euh qui sont qui sont important là
aujourd'hui ce M encore dans les
colonnes de l'indépendant on évoque un
projet contesté d'urbanisation au sud de
Perpignan il y a quelques semaines de ça
les travaux pour un golf ont commencé
enfin rendez-vous compte qu'on fait un
golf dans Les pyes Orientales le
département qui est le plus touché par
la sécheresse euh donc la question que
j'ai envie de poser à Jean c'est est-ce
qu'il serait pas important pour tous les
pour tous les politiques de ce
département euh et ben de de de créer
une sorte de d'électrochoc à ce
niveau-là parce que on sait très bien
que les élus au plan local c'est
extrêmement difficile pour eux de de
calmer cette urbanisation et que ça
serait peut-être aujourd'hui le le le
l'un des mesures à prendre pour
l'avenir alors bon tout d'abord bonjour
monsieur mathtis bon cette pause
urbanistique elle va elle va
effectivement s'imposer à nous euh je ne
suis pas convaincu que ce soit la la la
la seule piste hein moi je je je fais
référence hein si vous voulez au au
rapportin là aussi du Sénat auquel j'ai
j'ai collaboré dans le cadre de la
délégation à la prospective he qui a
travaillé sur l'avenir de la gestion à
horizon 2050 et qui a débouché quand
même sur une dizaine de propositions
dont s'est emparé hein le le le
gouvernement dans le cadre de son plan
national de 50 actions avec avec des des
des enfin en tout cas des des des
propositions qui qui me semblent tout
naturellement euh réalisable enfin
possible à à mettre en place rapidement
parce que dans cette problématique là il
y a des actions à très court terme nous
sommes dans dans l'urgence hein vous
l'avez dit euh monsieur mathtis hein
puisque le printemps est là l'été 2024
est là euh ça fait quand même une ou
deux années que nous que nous galérons
mais il faut donc il y a des actions à
très court terme des actions à moyen
terme et à long terme donc à un moment
donné il faut effectivement se mettre
autour d'une table et fixer le et fixer
le cap alors il y a pas de solution il y
a pas de solution magique déjà si vous
voulez la charte qui a été passé entre
entre les services préfectoraux de
l'État et et nos maires ont quand même
porté leurs fruits puisque ils ont fait
une économie à peu près de 30 % de hein
dans dans la dans la consommation d'eau
potable en passe en en plus alors en
parallèle moi je pense qu'il faut aller
très très rapidement sur les
réalisations de de de de de stations de
de réutilisation des EAU usées hein ça
ça peut être c'est c'est une c'est une
piste les retenues les retenues cinaires
aussi me semble me semble aussi être
être une piste et puis peut-être
monsieur Matis va-t-il falloir se poser
la question hein de l'arrivée de l'eau
duurone qui s'arrête dans le l'ode et
qui pourrait je pense hein alors c'est
sûr que ça va coûter énormément
aujourd'hui puisque on a tellement d'en
nez pour en tout cas pour réfléchir et
le et le mettre en place mais je pense
qu'il faudra effectivement se se se
poser la question et peut-être à moyen
ou long terme s'interrogait aussi sur la
la la la la nécessité et la pertinence
he de de s'orienter vers des usines de
de désalinisation quoi qu'il en soit
c'est c'est une une problématique
singulière moi je dirais historique dans
notre département euh qui ne pourra
s'améliorer en tout cas qu'avec le
concours de toutes les bonnes volontés
hein c'est-à-dire nos administrés les
élus euh bien évidemment le but étant
ben d'arriver quand même à à à à ce
qu'on est non seulement de l'eau hein
pour pour consommer on a quand même été
nous confronter à à cette problématique
puis certaines communes monsieur Matis
ne l'a pas dit mais mais n'avait plus
d'eau potable à un moment donné hein il
a fallu acheter des des palette d'eau
hein pour pour pour servir les
administrés et puis il y a un gros sujet
hein sur les les suite des réseaux ça
c'est quelque chose aujourd'hui que l'on
doit pouvoir traiter assez rapidement
alors qui est déjà engagé par par le
gouvernement des mesures qui ont été
annoncées par Emmanuel Macron il y a
plusieurs mois déjà là-dessus vous en
attendez plus sur la gestion de l'eau
Marc fenau sur la question des
agriculteurs parlent d'un fond
hydraulique est-ce qu'il faut en faire
plus également sur la question des
bassines ben moi je parle pas de
bassines à l'échelle de notre
département moi je parle plutôt de
retenue de retenue cinaire dont
l'implantation avait aidé déjà étudié
hein par les les les les les les
différentes chambres de présidents de
chambrees d'agriculture he qui se sont
qui qui se sont succédés mais moi je
pense qu'il y a un gros travail en tout
cas une poursuite d'un gros travail à
faire sur les fuites et qui sont sur les
réseaux mais ensuite vous allez me dire
oui mais il faut les moyens donc il va
falloir là aussi hein que l'État Vienne
aider les collectivités les budgets des
collectivités territoriales pour
accélérer ce processus de de de de
réparation de colmatage des fuites dans
un premier temps et puis mettre en œuvre
les quelques les quelques propositions
que je viens de faire qui sont dans
notre rapport au niveau du du Sénat et
qui font l'objet du plan national
d'action qui a été présenté il y a
quelques mois par le gouvernement merci
Pierre merci beaucoup on regarde la Une
de l'indépendant pierre Matis merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous pour nous
parler évidemment de cette problématique
très importante dans Les pyrénaes
Orientales merci un dernier mot sur
cette question de la crise agricole
jeans puisqu'on est à pierrepignon qui
est dirigé par le rassemblement national
est-ce que cette crise agricole selon
vous elle est en train de profiter au
rassemblement national non moi je ne
suis pas convaincu que cette crise
agricole profite au Fond national cette
crise cadricole cette crise agricole à
mon sens c'est la problématique de de de
tous hein et qu'il faut que chacun hein
en tout cas apporte sa sa sa sa pierre
moi je suis pas convaincu qu'elle en
tout cas personnellement c'est un avis
personnel qu'elle qu'elle profite à qui
que ce soit malheureusement elle
desserent nos agriculteurs nos maréchés
nos arboriculteurs et nos éleveurs alors
on va parler de l'actualité du Sénat et
cet après-midi sera examiné un texte sur
le Bien Vieillir alors qu'en 2030 une
personne sur 3 aura plus de 65 ans dans
notre pays que contient ce texte dont
vous êtes le rapporteur on va voir ça
avec Mathias
[Musique]
SZ bonjour Mathias bonjouri bonjour
monsieur le sénateur bonjour et Mathias
l'examen de la proposition doit pour
bâtir la société du bienvir débute donc
aujourd'hui au Sénat ouais une une loi
essentielle he pour l'avenir Orian
puisque'entre 2020 et 2030 la population
des 7584 ans va passer de 4,1 million à
6,1 une croissance de 49 % qui cumulé au
au recul de la natalité changera le
visage de notre société par exemple il y
aura alors plus de personnes ayant 65
ans et plus que des moins de 15 ans ce
texte donc après un examen en deux temps
à l'Assemblée nationale démarre sa 2uxè
vie ici au Sénat une version largement
élaguée par les sénateurs de la
commission des Affaires sociales et de
la commission des lois puisqu'il est
passé de 65 articles à 34 les
rapporteurs dont le sénateur Jean solul
ici présent fait partie avec la
centriste Joceline guidz ils ont
souhaité recentrer le texte sur son
contenu utile reprécisant certaines
choses et allégant au passage des
mesures jugées superflu inop érente ou
déjà satisfaite par le droit actuel
alors Mathias que contient précisément
ce texte alors premièrement il y a un
grand volet sur la promotion de la
biraitance envers les aînés on y
retrouve par exemple la consécration
d'un droit de visite pour les résidents
un droit absolu même en période de crise
sanitaire de visiter quotidiennement un
malade ou un résident en fin de vie le
renforcement du contrôle des épades on
rappelle le scandale du groupe Orpa de
début 2022 ou encore la création d'une
instance territoriale sous l'ég de
l'agence régionale de santé et du
président du conseil départemental pour
recueillir les signalements de
maltraitance envers les personnes
vulnérables il y a également volé sur
les aides à domicile oui une profession
souvent malmenée pourtant si nécessaire
et qui va être amené à le devenir de
plus en plus il y a donc au moins une
mesure symbolique d'abord avec la
création d'une carte professionnelle de
l'accompagnement qui devra faciliter
l'exercice d'émission par ailleurs la
proposition de loi ouvre la possibilité
au département volontaire de mettre en
place des expérimentations relatives à
un financement des services autonomie à
domicile par des dotations forfaitaires
un nouveau mode de financement qui
pourrait mieux rémunérer les
professionnels et faciliter l'accès à
leurs services par des personnes dans le
besoin euh j'en Solle dans les départ
dans les apports du Sénat il y a aussi
la création d'un guichet unique le
service public départemental de
l'autonomie pour informer et orienter
les personnes âgées face à la perte
d'autonomie est-ce que cela pourrait
être une piste selon vous pour mieux
accompagner les gens dans le besoin moi
je pense effectivement hein que la la
enfin cette cette cette arrivée dans le
texte du service public département de
de l'autonomie peut jouer ce rôle hein
notamment euh quand quand on voit les
les les difficultés parfois d'engager
des des des démarches hein notamment
administrative et sur le plan de la de
la coordination que vivent donc les les
familles he de nos personnes âgées et de
nos handicapés euh et les proches aidant
aussi et les personnes de de confiance
je pense effectivement que ce service
public départemental de l'autonomie peut
apporter peut apporter à mon avis
quelque chose puisqu'il est quand même
issu du rapport de de Dominique Libau
hein dont il y aurait quatre missions
une mission d'accueil enfin
d'information d'accueil et et
d'orientation une mission plus centrée
sur la la gestion des droits euh la
troisième mission serait serait en
direction si vous voulez des de de de de
l'assistance et du soutien aux
professionnels de santé et une 4e
mission serait concernerait des actions
d'information de prévention de repérage
et et d'aller vert et et j'ai envie de
dire de dire moi à ce niveau-là qu'il
serait en tout cas utile et
particulièrement intéressant d'incrire
la la personne euh la personne âgée ou
le ou le l'handicapé sur un parcours une
sorte de de de continuum hein qui qui
partirait à partir de de l'utilisation
hein de de l'outil icop sur le le
repérage des des facteurs de de risque
qui permettrai de mettre en place un
plan d'action qui pourrait être suivi
hein par ce par ce spda et qui
inscrirait la la personne âgée ou
l'handicapé sur une un continuum he sur
un un un parcours type parcours patient
dans nos établissements de de de de
santé aujourd'hui qui partirait donc à
partir de je le répète de la prévention
de cette prévention des risques en
matière de d'autonomie en utilisant
cette cet outil et en mettant en place
un plan d'action du virage domiciliaire
qui permettrait donc à nos personnes
âgées à nos handicapés de rester à
domicile le plus longtemps possible en
bonne santé ensuite nous pourrions
préparer la transition vers les
résidences autonomie résidence senior
béginage la trème étape serait l'entrée
dans un épade et la 4ème étape serait
malheureusement l'entrée dans une unité
de soins de longue durée qui est
beaucoup plus médicalisée Maas on le
voit ce ce texte éit plein de bonne
volonté pour autant la commission des
affaires sociales résume la proposition
de loi n'entraînera pas de
bouleversement des politiques de soutien
à l'autonomie est-ce que c'est un coup
d'épé dans l'eau voir un échec alors moi
je n'irai pas jusqu'à dire que c'est un
coup un coup d'épé dans l'eau ça quand
même le mérite d'exister après je pense
effectivement personnellement et et mes
collègues sont sur la même longueur
d'onde qu'elle ne répond que
partiellement euh à cette transition
démographique voir épidémiologique et
qui qu'est-ce qui manque à ben moi je
pense qu'il manque un en tout cas alors
ce qu'il manque et ce qu'il va manquer à
mon avis mais qui devrait se traduire
dans la dans la loi de programmation
pluriannuelle hein qui est annoncée dans
ce texte à l'article 2 c'est la question
des moyens qui sont attendus par tous
les acteurs que nous avons auditionnés
hein tout au long de la de la de la
préparation des délibérations donc qui
qui démarrre cet après-midi dans le dans
dans l'hémicycle il y a il y a il y a si
vous voulez il y a il y a un mê pas en
direction du virage domiciliaire
euh quand on sait le travail
effectivement vous l'avez souligné de
nos aide à domicile je pense qu'il faut
aller plus loin hein ça n'est pas une
carte professionnelle à mon avis qui va
régler les problèmes euh l'idée
intéressante vous c'est ça la priorité
c'est travailler sur le maintien à
domicile des personnes âgées pour leur
éviter d'aller dans les épades dans les
maison de retraite oui il y a un gros
travail sur le virage à Dom à
domiciliaire mais il faut se donner les
moyens mais nous savons toutes et tous
pour avoir des parents des
grands-parents que le le maintien à
domicile à un moment donné il a des
limites et et que donc il faut préparer
nos aînés nos handicapés à cette
transition vers une résidence SEOR une
résidence autonomie hein du Béguinage he
un habitat inclusif partagé la troisème
étape pourrait être donc cette entrée
dans dans dans dans dans un épad hein
c'est c'est c'est c'est pas facile et
puis il il y a la question des des
moyens financiers
on va parler de la loi dans quelques
instants mais il y a aussi la question
d'un manque de personnel de
l'attractivité de ces métiers comment on
résout cette question alors sur la sur
la partie aide à domicile moi je pense
qu'il y a des manques he sur
l'attractivité des métiers c'est une
très bonne question euh effectivement ça
n'est pas une carte professionnelle à
mon avis qui va qui va faire que le ce
métier qui qui est compliqué qui est
difficile he nous l' nous ont démontré
quand même he pendant la crise sanitaire
qu'elles étaient là et qu'elles
répondaient aux besoins je pense qu' il
va falloir la sortir d'une formation il
va falloir la sortir d'un statut bien
évidemment d'une rémunération mais quand
vous parlez de l'attractivité des
métiers j'ai envie de dire aussi qu'il
va falloir se préoccuper de
l'attractivité des métiers du personnel
soignant dans les épades dans les
services de gériatrie et c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles je propose moi
depuis de nombreuses années la création
d'une infirmière quelque peu spécialisée
en gériatrie ou en géronau psychiatrie
ou de une infirmière en pratique avancée
grand âge comme le préconise depuis un
long moment le professeur jandel alors
on parle des moyens justement une loi de
programmation financière pour cette
politique pour les CIN prochaines années
avaient été promis par le gouvernement
c'était alors Aurore berger qui était
ministre des Solidarités est-ce que vous
avez toujours espoir que cette loi
arrive écoutez moi non seulement j'ai
l'espoir euh parce que je crois qu'il
faut garder le moral mais je l'appelle
et et nous l'appelons de nos vux he
parce que c'est bien joli à un moment
donné de faire un certain nombre de
déclarations d'intention euh en
direction de la perte d'autonomie de
l'entrée dans laindépendance du Bien
vieillir en France mais à un moment
donné on ne pourra pas faire l'économie
effectivement des moyens bon madame aur
Berger s'y était engagé madame Vautrin
notre nouvelle ministre que nous avons
auditionné s'est engagé donc cette loi
de programmation pluriannuelle devrait
arriver à la fin du premier premier
semestre pardon 2024 voire 2 semestre
2024 et bien évidemment nous espérons
que ça va se traduire par des moyens
financiers en sachant quand même que ce
n'est pas les moyens financiers qui vont
tout résoudre hein on a pas parlé euh et
je pense que c'est peut-être l'occasion
l'opportunité m donneré d'en parler
c'est le fameux taux d'encadrement hein
pour les éepades en particulier qui est
aujourd'hui en desessà des des des
besoins et de la réponse à un besoin
puisque vous savez comme moi que les
résidents sont sont de plus en plus en
tout cas sont porteurs de de plus en
plus de polypathologie de maladies
neurodégénératives et qui demande de
plus en plus de so qu'udelà de cette loi
de programmation financière il est temps
d'avoir une grande loi sur le grand âge
sur la dépendance elle est promise par
Emmanuel Macron depuis 2017 elle est
promises oui depuis 7 ou 8 ans bien sûr
bien sûr il est temps qu'elle arrive
alors il y a quand même un certain
nombre de de pistes dans la loi qui nous
est présenté aujourd'hui maintenant il
faudra qu'elle se traduise de manière
donc ça suffit ou vous dites là il faut
une loi grand âge bien sûr il faut
surtout des des des des moyens
financiers même si je je vous le disais
il y a quelques instants ce n'est pas
les finances qui vont tout régler il y a
des questions managériales il y a des
questions hein organisationnelles il y a
des questions d'équilibre entre vie
professionnelle et vie personnelle euh
notamment et puis surtout permettre à
nos soignants et en tout cas ces acteurs
de l'aide à domicile de passer beaucoup
plus de temps auprès des résidents et
des handicapés que sur des tâches
administratives merci Mathias merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous et merci
jeanol merci de nous avoir accompagné
pendant cette première demiure